vous imaginez le résultat conserver
difficile parce que je pense qu'on ne va
essayer de prendre sa revanche sur le
match de coupe
je vais à paris et on a toujours du mal
de jouer contre elle parce que c'est une
équipe très difficile à jouer très bonne
équipe aussi
oui et je crois que on aura du mal à
faire ce résultat mais enfin je pense
que ce sera ça sera un si bon match
correct soulette paris il enfin j'espère
oui en fait l'un des tous meilleurs
matchs que vous y faites saison comme
les rennais s'étaient au paris des
droits des princes mais on a eu beaucoup
disent encore on a gagné on a eu
beaucoup plus de réussite q quel est le
problème pour vous dans ce match contre
rennes quel est le problème le plus
difficile à résoudre
est ce au niveau de la ligne d'attaqué
rennaise ou au niveau de la défense
autour de moi enfin moi personnellement
très des fois ça je croise une attaque
un gars comme toi que tu sais enfin pour
moi parce que je trouve
très bon joueur et difficile a remarqué
mois puis attaque a causé pour notre
bonjour aussi tu as catch est un
problème on va se tourner maintenant
vers joseph bonnel joseph bonnel vous
êtes l'élément moteur de cette équipe
marseillaise
à votre avis pensez vous que cette
rencontre peut balancer en faveur de
l'olympique de marseille
alors que l'olympique de marseille a été
battu à metz mercredi dernier mais avant
de commencer le match
on espère toujours réussir un bon
résultat mais comme on améliore câblage
et penser que ce sera un match très
difficile car ils voudront à tout prix
nous battre la romanche de la coupe
c'est très normal est ici sont pas
faciles à manier
déjà l'année dernière nous étions
février trois heures et on s'en sort
très bien